Speaker 1: And according to Washington Post
reporter Jennifer Rubin. That's going to come
back to bite Republicans in the 2024 election.
Jennifer Rubin with The Washington Post had
a great new article this week. The title
is Right Wing Judges May Cripple the GOP.
And she spends about a page and a half talking,
of course, about last week's ruling with regard to
the Texas judge who banned the abortion pill, used
a bunch of activist language in the ruling. You
know, completely violated the I think it's a six
year statute of limitations to even challenge the
FDA on a drug being on the market because manifest
prone. I forgot how to say it. I'm so sorry.
Mifepristone. Misoprostol. Yeah. If ever stoned
has been on the market for 20 years. So the
judge way missed the statute of limitations, but
still decided, nope, I'm going to ban it anyway
and the public's pissed. And that's what
Jennifer Rubin is talking about. So let me
read this from Rubin's article again. I think
it's very well written and I think it's very
on point. Here. It is. It is one thing to gin
up the base on the on invented threats from
critical race theory or the great replacement
theory. But when the MAGA movement's judges
begin to inflict radically unpopular edicts
on those outside the right wing audience,
that risk sparking a counter response, a
determined, broad based movement insistent
that the United States not turn the clock back on
decades of social progress. Republican setbacks,
such as the disappointing 2022 midterms.
A progressive Democrat last week winning a
crucial Wisconsin Supreme Court seat and rising
support for abortion rights over the past year,
suggest that conservatives may have won the
battle to stack the courts with ideologues,
but might be losing the war for public opinion
and ultimately electoral control. The more
the Supreme Court diverges from overwhelming
public sentiment on issues such as abortion,
guns and voting rights, the more strength and
more allies the progressive movement may gain.
I kind of like the sound of that. Now, it's
obviously not worth losing our rights in the
meantime, because God only knows if we're ever
going to get them back. But Ruben's overall theory
is that it's one thing for these horrible
Republican politicians like what we have down
here in Florida, you know, to push the CRT bands,
to push the transgender bands to go after woke
Disney and, you know, the same things happening in
Texas with the bands in Oklahoma and all the red
states. It's one thing to do it at the state
level because you're doing it to an audience
that typically likes these things because, as
I previously said, they don't understand them.
But when the judges come in, those decisions
aren't local. Those decisions are national.
Meaning they don't just affect the red
states. They're affecting the blue states,
but more importantly, they're
affecting those swing states.
Kind of like the overturning of Roe did
last summer. That played a massive role
in what happened in the 2022 midterm elections.
We even saw red states like a Kansas veto on
their ballot in 2022, a ban on abortion. So even
in red states, these things aren't that popular.
And if these judges continue
down this path, as Ruben says,
you're handing 2024 to the Democrat. Well, to
the progressive, she says, which even better.
Hand it to us. We'll take it. We'll
fix the problems. We have ideas.
We have better ideas than Republicans have because
R&D ideas don't involve tax cut. Tax cut, tax cut.
But in the meantime, people suffer. And that's
not okay. That's not okay at all. These activist
judges are doing the job that Republicans
put them there to do. And the voters need
to remember that when they head to the polls next
year. Yes, the judges might be the ones doing it,
but you have to punish at the ballot the ones
who put those judges there in the first place.
Otherwise, you're going to end up with more
Republican activist judges giving even worse
rulings than what we've already seen. I am Ferron
cousin, sitting in for David Pakman. Don't forget
you can find me at YouTube.com slash the ring of
fire, youtube.com, slash fair and balanced and all
across social media at fair and balanced. We'll
be right back with more on the David Pakman show.